[Música]
no es ningún secreto Japón tiene
problemas unos cuantos problemas pero de
todos ellos hay uno que destaca con
mucha fuerza la profunda crisis
demográfica que está experimentando el
país amigos Japón parece condenado a ir
poco a poco desapareciendo es algo de lo
que ya os hemos hablado hace un tiempo
aquí en visual politic os dejo el vídeo
en la descripción atentos por ejemplo a
este titular
la población de Japón se reduce en cerca
de 800,000 personas con caídas en todas
las prefecturas por primera vez Pese a
que los residentes extranjeros
aumentaron un 10% en los últimos 14 años
durante ese mismo periodo la población
japonesa ha ido cayendo cada año de
forma ininterrumpida de hecho las
estimaciones apuntan a que Durante los
próximos 40 años Japón perderá casi 40
millones de habitantes un millón de
personas por año de media por supuesto
Durante este tiempo la población también
será más y más y más mayor ahora bien
puede que algunos os estéis pregun
prando pero Enrique qué diantes tiene
todo esto que ver con el título de este
vídeo Acaso no se supone que íbamos a
hablar de las fuerzas de autodefensa de
Japón pues veréis la realidad es que
esta crisis demográfica afecta a todos
los terrenos al económico al político y
sí también al militar Y es que veréis
según algunos analistas el declive
demográfico que se va a producir tanto
en Asia como en gran parte del mundo
desarrollado podría Conducir a una
situación de paz forzada es lo que
algunos conocen como la paz geriátrica
según esos analistas el envejecimiento
de la población generará una nueva
estabilidad geopolítica especialmente
teniendo en cuenta que tanto china como
Rusia se enfrentan también a serios
problemas
demográficos esta teoría apunta a que
como habrá menos jóvenes disponibles en
la fuerza laboral se priorizará que
estos se dediquen a trabajar en la
economía productiva para poder sostener
el sistema de bienestar pensad que en
las poblaciones muy envejecidas los
gastos sanitarios y de dependencia se
disparan Y eso lo tiene que sostener
alguien precisamente por este motivo
esta teoría sostiene que habrá menos
jóvenes disponibles y también dispuestos
a enrolarse en las fuerzas armadas o
hacer el servicio militar en
consecuencia según señala esta teoría
los países serán más reacios a actuar de
forma agresiva apostando más por
solucionar los problemas de forma
diplomática ahora bien tiene sentido
todo esto pues puede que en algunos
lugares esta teoría se cumpla desde
luego Lo siento pero esta vez no seremos
nosotros los que digamos ni una cosa ni
la otra ni tampoco la contraria ahora
bien en Japón que es el país más
envejecido del mundo y algo deben saber
de todo esto no parece que compre mucho
esta idea queréis saber por qué Pues
bien prestad mucha pero que mucha
atención porque en este tercer vídeo en
colaboración con Harvard International
review os vamos a contar cómo las
fuerzas de autodefensa de Japón esperan
reforzarse en una época en la que habrá
muchos menos efectivos disponibles os
estamos hablando Ni más ni menos que del
nuevo Tecno ejército de Japón
[Música]
atentos menos hombres más máquinas
fijaos un momento En este gráfico lejos
de reducirse los últimos años y
especialmente desde el 2017 el gasto
militar de Japón respecto al pib no ha
parado de crecer en 2020 de hecho
alcanzó por primera vez desde finales de
los años 50 El 1% del pib pero amigos
eso no es nada Comparado con lo que se
viene el plan de Japón es incrementar su
gasto militar hasta cerca del 2% del pib
siguiendo el estándar de la otan de aquí
al año 2027 esto es mucho pero que
muchísimo dinero pensad que Japón es una
economía enorme Así que estamos hablando
a medio plazo de entre 40 y 50,000
millones de dólares más de gasto militar
cada año las fuerzas de autodefensa de
Japón se convertirán así en las terceras
de todo el mundo en términos
presupuestarios hablamos amigos de una
apuesta militar que no solo nos
demuestra que el envejecimiento
demográfico No necesariamente conducirá
a un menor peso de las fuerzas armadas
sino que puede ser incluso todo lo
contrario Por qué pues si miramos a
Japón vamos a poder encontrar una
posible respuesta la futura falta de
personal en las fuerzas armadas se
quiere sustituir por tecnología y
máquinas un cambio que conlleva gastar
una cantidad descomunal de dinero para
que hagáis una idea Japón quiere
inyectar unos 320,000 millones de
dólares entre 2023 y 2027 a sus fuerzas
armadas y sí esto es mucho pero que
muchísimo
[Música]
dinero el objetivo nipon tal y como
marca su última estrategia de defensa
nacional que es del año 2022 pasa por
crear unas fuerzas armadas más pequeñas
en número de efectivos pero muchísimo
más letales es decir convertir un
ejército normal en un ejército de
unidades de élite bien entrenado muy
bien equipado y con una gran dotación de
tecnología y además es algo que se
quiere lograr utilizando sobre todo
tecnología autóctona Para ello el
gobierno japonés esperará disparar el
gasto en imas de militar y aprovecharse
también de limas de civil como nunca
antes supone un cambio total de
paradigma ahora bien todo esto
exactamente Por qué Qué explica que de
repente Japón quisiera ponerse las pilas
pues aparte de lo que os hemos contado
sobre el reto demográfico la explicación
la podemos encontrar sobre todo en China
amigos Japón se siente cada vez más y
más vulnerable respecto a las crecientes
capacidades militares del gigante
asiático y el discurso cada vez más
hostil con occidente de los gerifaltes
de Pekín ojo no solo en términos
militares sino también políticos de
hecho llama mucho la atención que el
país del sol naciente a pesar de ser la
tercera economía mundial parece tener
poca influencia internacional pensadlo
bien alguna vez tenéis en cuenta la
opinión de tokyio en los grandes debates
internacionales Pues eso
si quitáis su pertenencia al g7
hablaríamos de un país que la verdad
pinta muy poco en la Esfera política
internacional países como Alemania o
Canadá teniendo economías más pequeñas
tienen mucho más peso internacional
incluso Corea del Sur que se ha
convertido en un importante proveedor en
el sector de la defensa y de la energía
civil ya rivaliza con el peso político
de Japón y eso queridos amigos es algo
que ahora el gobierno japonés también
quiere cambiar recientemente con su
entrada en alianzas militares como el
quad se ha empezado a revertir esta
situación pero lo cierto Es que hace
falta más y aquí contar con unas fuerzas
armadas realmente capaces puede resultar
fundamental tanto para la influencia
internacional como para la propia
seguridad nacional como ya os hemos
comentado en varias ocasiones pekin está
llevando a cabo un proceso de
modernización militar muy acelerado en
los últimos años las fuerzas armadas
chinas cada vez están mejor
equipadas algunos analistas militares
ponen incluso fecha para que china logre
estar preparada para invadir Taiwán si
así lo quisiera el año 202 7 y claro
dada la experiencia con la invasión rusa
de Ucrania ahora las amenazas militares
de Gigantes contra países más pequeños y
débiles se ha empezado a tomar mucho más
en serio En el caso de Taiwán una
hipotética invasión china tendría graves
implicaciones para Japón no solo dejaría
a sus Islas sud occidentales mucho más
expuestas a Pekín sino que además los
efectos sobre la economía japonesa
podrían llegar a ser devastadores Taiwán
produce buena parte de los
semiconductores y de la tecnología más
avanzada que demanda la industria
japonesa y hay muchas empresas niponas
que directamente fabrican allí si se
cortase ese suministro El golpe podría
ser letal Y por supuesto tampoco podemos
olvidarnos de Corea del Norte que ya ha
demostrado ser capaz de atacar cualquier
parte de Japón con misiles con capacidad
nuclear ahora bien echate el freno
Porque si pensáis que en este vídeo
Simplemente nos íbamos a limitar a
contar que Japón quiere comprar armas
más modernas Lo cierto es que no es así
Eso es tan solo el
principio el plan de Japón para
conseguir unas fuerzas armadas
totalmente distintas a como las
conocemos hoy en día va mucho pero que
muchísimo más allá por ejemplo
recientemente el Ministerio de defensa
nipon publicó las directrices de defensa
tecnológica de 2023 hablamos de un
documento que cambia radicalmente la
forma en la que las fuerzas armadas se
relacionan con la economía privada con
las universidades y hasta con el propio
gobierno lo que os vamos a contar a
continuación seguro que sorprende a más
de uno queridos amigos amigas Así es
como Japón quiere convertirse en uno de
los países más innovadores del mundo en
materia militar
[Música]
atentos una fuerza
Beta vale creo que no voy a descubrir la
pólvora si os digo que las fuerzas
armadas japonesas arrastran problemas de
capacidades importantes tras años y años
y años décadas de
de Estados Unidos para forzar la
capitulación de este país en la Segunda
Guerra Mundial la sociedad japonesa
quedó completamente traumatizada el país
que durante el siglo pasado fue un
régimen militarista imperialista que
causó un enorme reguero de destrucción y
de muerte por media Asia ahora es uno de
los países más pacifistas de todo el
planeta de hecho la inmensa mayoría de
los japoneses estaban en contra de
aumentar el gasto en defensa para que os
hagáis una idea a principios de la
década de 2010 apenas una cuarta parte
de Los japoneses se mostraban favorables
a incrementar el gasto militar Sin
embargo a día de hoy esa cifra ha subido
ya más del 60 por. del sus si al misil
guiado los gustos de Los japoneses han
cambiado radicalmente en apenas 10 años
Pues bien la cuestión ahora es que para
convertir el aumento del presupuesto en
resultados tangibles el gobierno de
fumio kisida que por cierto desciende de
una familia de Hiroshima la ciudad más
pacifista y antimilitarista del país ha
trazado una vía muy peculiar el Tecno
ejército y es que veréis hasta ahora el
ejército japonés se había centrado en
desarrollar armamento propio del tipo
convencional hablamos de tanques barcos
y aviones de combate sin embargo para
paralelamente La amenaza Más directa de
Japón que china ha estado trabajando en
armas no convencionales y altamente
tecnológicas hablamos por ejemplo de
armas de energía dirigidas con láser
armas electromagnéticas cañones de riel
o drones de todo tipo la Marina china
está probando el cañón helicoidal más
potente jamás construido las armas de
bobina también conocidas como
aceleradores magnéticos podrían provocar
cambios enormes en la forma en que se
libran Las Guerras allenando el camino
para ataques más devastadores contra
objetivos enemigos
china reivindica el desarrollo de un
cañón de riel electromagnético frente a
sus rivales Estados Unidos y Japón sobre
algunas de estas super armas ya os
hablamos en un pasado vídeo aquí en
visal politic que también os dejo la
descripción El caso es que todo esto
sumado a la cada vez mayor agresividad
en La retórica del régimen chino ha
hecho que Los japoneses se den cuenta de
que es muy pero que muy posible que de
seguir así las cosas pronto no puedan
hacer frente a una agresión por parte de
pequín y eso no es todo por supuesto
tampoco serían capaces de defender sus
intereses en la región por ejemplo no
podrían hacer absolutamente nada
respecto a Taiwán su capacidad de
isolación sería absolutamente nula por
eso la pregunta la gran pregunta que
podemos hacernos es cuál es la solución
que ha propuesto Tokio Pues básicamente
aprovechar una de las grandes fortalezas
de este país y disparar la investigación
y el desarrollo de nuevos tipos de
armamento pero ojo no de la forma en la
que se ha estado haciendo hasta
ahora hasta ahora las fuerzas de
autodefensa comunicaban al Ministerio de
defensa Cuáles eran las capacidades que
necesitaban después el Ministerio
estudiaba qué armamento tendría
preferencia y encargaba a contratistas
privados su desarrollo y fabricación
luego durante años la industria de
defensa iba construyendo prototipos que
probaban y probaban hasta la saciedad y
los iban mejorando hasta conseguir el
modelo final después ese modelo final
tenía que pasar por una certificación
del Ministerio de defensa antes de
entrar en
[Música]
servicio El caso es que este proceso
podía durar Entre 10 incluso 20 años
hasta que ese armamento entraba en
funcionamiento durante todo ese tiempo
además iban apareciendo muchas
tecnologías que simplemente se quedaban
fuera del producto final un ejemplo lo
tenemos en El Tanque tipo 90 un
armamento que las fuerzas de autodefensa
tardaron 13 años en desplegar desde que
se solicitó hasta que se completó el
diseño final es decir el resultado con
este modelo de producción solía ser un
productor relativamente desfasado O al
menos uno que ya no estaba a la
vanguardia de la industria militar Este
modelo de diseño y desarrollo es lo que
se conoce como modelo en cascada cada
paso del proceso va uno detrás del otro
y no se empieza el siguiente hasta que
se completa El anterior Pues bien Esto
es exactamente con lo que el Ministerio
de defensa de Japón quiere ahora acabar
de raíz acabar de una vez por todas con
el modelo enc cascada y la pregunta es
cómo hacerlo Pues de una forma que igual
a muchos os llama la atención y a otros
incluso os puede llegar a escandalizar
hablamos de promover la fusión de la
imas de militar y la imas de civil o al
menos eso es lo que se plantea en la
práctica y sí ya sé lo que puede que
muchos estéis pensando pero Enrique
acaso Esto no es algo parecido a lo que
hace china Pues sí en esencia Sí pero
con matices como siempre El está
en los
detalles en un horizonte de 10 o más
años vista Japón quiere que las empresas
privadas con componente de iasd así como
las universidades se unan a las
instituciones y agencias públicas de
investigación tanto civiles como
militares y al propio Ministerio de
defensa para trabajar codo con codo lo
que se busca es que las tecnologías
civiles más avanzadas como los mejores
drones la Inteligencia artificial o
numerosos software de análisis masivo de
datos se pueda fusionar e integrar
rápidamente para crear armas remotas e
incluso autónomas La idea es conseguir
la superioridad tecnológica y al mismo
tiempo reducir a la mínima expresión la
cantidad de hombres necesarios para
realizar operaciones militares o en
otras palabras lanzar más máquinas al
campo de batalla en caso de necesitarlo
y menos
personas Japón lanza una agencia de
investigación de tecnología de defensa y
avanza un proyecto de cañón de riel todo
esto que os acabamos de contar tendría
como mínimo un par de ventajas y un par
de
inconvenientes la primera ventaja es que
en un escenario de envejecimiento y
caída de la población Japón podría
mantener e incluso mejorar sus
capacidades de defensa lo cual no se
creía posible bajo la teoría de la paz
geriátrica la segunda ventaja es que en
caso de conflicto se arriesgaría muchas
menos vidas japonesas pero ojo porque
también podemos encontrar algunas
desventajas la primera por supuesto es
su coste desarrollar un ejército con
estas capacidades resulta carísimo y se
comería buena parte de esos 321,000
millones de dólares de gasto militar que
hemos dicho se contemplan hasta el año
2027 y luego la segunda desventaja que
puede tener Es la insensibilización y la
deshumanización de la guerra y esto al
final se podría traducir en más víctimas
civiles en caso de conflicto y guerras
más cruentas es decir un resultado muy
diferente al esperado ahora bien Es todo
esto realista Seguro seguro que muchos
estáis pensando madre mía vaya película
se han montado Los japoneses verdad pues
lo cierto Es que a falta eso sí de que
haya planes más concretos las
directrices parecen muy serias y las
fuerzas armadas de Japón van a ir por
este camino durante esta Y al menos la
próxima
década de hecho uno de los grandes
Pilares de esta nueva estrategia es que
el modelo en cascada de desarrollo de
armas se ha desterrado para siempre
según este nuevo enfoque las armas
desarrolladas conjuntamente por la
industria de la defensa y el sector
civil entrarían en funcionamiento en las
fuerzas de autodefensa En fase prototipo
en cuanto tuvieran funcionalidades
reales de combate empezarían a ser
utilizadas
luego serían los propios reportes por
parte de las fuerzas armadas los que
harían mejorar esos prototipos a lo
largo de los años hasta llegar a un
producto final totalmente funcional
vamos unas fuerzas armadas En fase Beta
constante Ahora bien Por qué se quiere
hacer esto por qué tantas prisas Pues
básicamente amigos por lo que os hemos
comentado antes Los japoneses creen que
china les está comiendo el terreno en
materia de tecnología militar y tienen
que apretar cueste lo que cueste para
mantener su capacidad de disuasión y
combate además en el nuevo plan también
está contemplado que todo el nuevo
armamento desarrollado por Japón tenga
estándares otan de esta forma se podría
mejorar la interoperabilidad con sus
aliados y también facilitar la
exportación del nuevo armamento que se
desarrolle pero ahora bien llegados a
este punto La pregunta es queréis
ejemplos concretos de lo que Japón tiene
entre manos bajo este nuevo
esquema pues veréis al margen de mejorar
el cañón de riel que ya se ha probado
incluso sobre un barco Japón Busca
desarrollar una serie de nuevas armas no
convencionales no tripuladas o incluso
autónomas armas Ultra conectadas a las
redes como la 5g G que se pueden usar
desde miles de kilómetros de distancia
aprovechando la bajísima latencia de
estas nuevas redes Pero hay más una de
las cosas que primero Quieren poner en
funcionamiento es un sistema de
microondas de alta potencia hablamos de
un arma de energía dirigida para en el
caso de Japón hacer frente a ataques de
saturación con drones también se busca
priorizar el uso de tipos no
convencionales de energía para hacer
funcionar el armamento y la creación de
nuevos materiales en teoría mucho más
perfecto
de hecho en las directrices recién
publicadas se hace referencia al
desarrollo de un nuevo material que no
solo sea más resistente sino que tenga
una microestructura perfecta capaz
incluso de regenerarse y no no es broma
pero amigos las ideas de Japón para el
futuro no solo se quedan en tecnologías
aplicables al armamento ofensivo también
buscan utilizar armas mucho menos
comunes de las que os podáis imaginar un
ejemplo pues veréis Japón quiere crear
verdaderos sistemas de propagación de
información falsa sí de fake news de
toda la vida vida pero llevadas a otra
división me explico a través de la
Inteligencia artificial el metaverso y
de tecnologías muy avanzadas de Deep
fake o incluso a través de la proyección
de hologramas estereoscópicos Japón
quiere engañar al enemigo tanto dentro
como fuera del campo de batalla cóm pues
ni más ni menos que dispersando toda esa
información para hacer creer cosas que
no son y ganar ventaja en caso de
conflicto incluso hablan de proyectar
objetos como si fueran reales
hablaríamos de tecnologías que en mayor
o menor medida ya se empiezan a usar en
la Esfera civil pero que el ejército de
Japón quiere adoptar adaptar y mejorar
hasta su máxima expresión para
convertirlas en armas auténticamente
letales vale puede que para muchos todo
esto que os estamos contando resulte una
auténtica locura Y no creáis que no os
entendemos pero os digo una cosa todo lo
que os estamos contando Aparecen las
nuevas directrices de defensa
tecnológica Así que sí Esto es lo que
Japón tiene entre manos ahora la duda la
gran duda que todos seguramente tengamos
es lo conseguirán se convertirán las
fuerzas armadas de Japón en unas fuerzas
futuristas Ultra conectadas y super
mecanizadas Pues bien solo el tiempo
dirá y seguro que aquí en visual
política hablaremos de ello más pronto
que tarde Por el momento podéis dejarnos
vuestras opiniones por aquí abajo en los
comentarios espero amigos que este nuevo
vídeo entre visual politic y Harvard
International review os seya resultado
tan Interesante como a nosotros si es
así no olvidéis darle al botón de like y
suscribiros a visual politic si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la
[Música]
próxima